turning overseas now and the protests in
Iran which are not letting up after the
family of a young woman says she was
tortured and killed in police custody it
all happened because she was accused of
a dress code violation not properly
wearing her hijab
Masha amini's death has sparked 11 days
of protest and counting against the
country's religious leaders there and we
found Remy inocencio in London following
it all for us and recently in
conversation with amini's cousin Remy
good morning
Good morning Tony that's right and there
have been protests happening outside of
Iran's embassies really around the world
including like here in London you can
actually take a look and you can see the
red paint That's splattered on the
facade right here but you know all this
really doesn't matter when it comes to
Iran's government they really don't care
they're still cracking down and it was
all sparked by the death of one young
woman
with Defiance and despair yes
family friends and Village Neighbors in
the thousands buried 22 year old Masa
amini her family tells CBS News police
killed her she was tortured according to
eyewitnesses says irfanzai masa's
activist cousin in Exile in Iraq
she was tortured in the van after her
arrest then tortured at the police
station for half an hour then hit on her
head and she collapsed no police claim
from a heart attack in official
Coroner's report pending her father says
she was beaten to death by morality
police and forcers of Iran's strict
dress code her head covering reportedly
too loose Masa amini's death has since
become a rallying crime sparking
protests across dozens of cities and
towns women removing their required head
coverings and burning them their Embers
and emotions Rising into the night skies
men joining them to protest a regime
they all denounce as repressive on top
of Prussian sanctions Rising inflation
and rampant poverty
many chant death to the dictator Iran's
supreme leader Iran's military says they
are ready to deal with its enemies are
the people protesting enemies of the
government
the people of Iran want human rights a
peaceful country and regime change of
course this is how they're treated
videos show what appear to be live
ammunition tear gas and water cannons
and mounting injuries and deaths the
regime has organized pro-government
rallies in a public relations pushback
and cut access to the internet to keep
people from organizing and sharing
videos like these with the world
the protests against Iran's regime have
formed from Atlanta to Istanbul
Paris
and London
if you could tell the Ayatollah one
thing what would it be
dictatory the old dictator is in his
last days
an international condemnation continues
to rise President Biden has already
sanctioned the morality police in Iran
but Iran for its part is actually
blaming the West especially the United
States for its troubles Gail
images are very tough to watch thank you
very much Remy